hello and welcome to intelligence squar
with me Kavita Puri we're recording in
London on May the 17th and I am very
excited to introduce Our Guest satnam
sangera times journalist bestselling
author his books include the excellent
the boy with a top knot marriage
material and of course Empire land which
was longlisted for the BTY gford prize
for non-fiction and won the nib book of
the year for non-fiction his new book
which we'll be discussing is stolen
history the truth about the British
Empire and how it shaped us it's an
introduction to the British Empire for
readers age nine and over but actually I
think it's great for anyone who wants to
learn about Empire and maybe was too
afraid to ask some difficult
questions satam welcome hello um like
you actually I worked out really late on
in my life life about Empire why I'm
here why my parents came to Britain and
reading this book um I felt it's the
book I wish I always had when I was
growing up I imagine it's the book that
you wish you had when you were growing
up yeah totally I mean I didn't learn
the basics of British Empire to my 40s
didn't study a single writer of color
into my final term at Cambridge and I
guess one of the biggest lessons I've
learned from from writing Empire land is
we are a Multicultural Society because
we had a multicultural Empire which
counteracts The Narrative I grew up with
which is that brown people came here
uninvited and took advantage of British
Hospitality that's been the narrative
about uh Imperial immigration during my
lifetime and certainly in Enoch pal
wolver Hampton when I grew up and I
think if I'd known that we're here for a
reason for deep reasons um it would have
changed my entire sense of myself in
Britain and for the better you you know
and the idea of giving kids that
knowledge feels amazing but also makes
me jealous and slightly angry that I I
never had that but also important not
just for kids who are brown to know that
but for other kids to know that history
too it's their history right absolutely
and a lot of the like the main
narratives we have about ourselves like
World War I World War II the tuders
there were Imperial elements to those
stories right the millions of black and
Asian soldiers in World War I and World
War II the black figures who were in The
Cor of Henry the 7th and Henry the eth
and it was never mentioned I sat through
dozens of Remembrance Day Services
throughout my youth no one ever said oh
your people were there too you know and
again I think it would have been a
really powerful thing to to tell a
racially diverse school like like mine
it's odd because like you as I say I
came to it late on in my life in my 40s
too it's weird isn't it to to have this
kind of Revelation this knowledge so
late on it is weird Amnesia is just
absolutely bizarre and like the number
of Oxford educated historians who've
been in touch with me to say oh I
learned nothing about the British Empire
until I did it myself in my 30s or 40s
is amazing and it's like it's almost
like a conspiracy and i' I've been
writing a I'm writing a sequel to Empire
land at the moment and one thing I've
really realized is that there are
several reasons for that that Amnesia
but one of them is that the British went
out of the way to delete knowledge and
delete documentation I mean there was a
pool of smoke over Delhi because they
were burning so many documents on
Independence but if you if you look at
what happened during the Mau Rebellion
the British destroyed all the documents
and I've been reading recently about the
establishment of Nigeria and like Goldie
one of the the not the rapper the guy
who was involved in the foundation of
Nigeria he deleted every single document
at the time like he knew it would not be
favorable and I think that was it was
pretty systematic
IC I mean it's interesting you talk
about that Amnesia because you explain
in the book why children don't know
about Empire and why people actually
might feel quite awkward discussing it
why was it important to tell children
that some people might feel angry when
they start a discussion about um Empire
I mean you even explain what selective
Amnesia is to them why did you decide to
do that and include that I think I mean
I didn't understand the basics of Empire
until my 40s but also I'm not I'm not an
historian and one thing I didn't
understand until I was an adult is that
history is argument I mean I did gcsc
history but I left school thinking that
history was a a list of Undisputed facts
and that's not true history is argument
based on hard facts and that is
transformative as an idea for me and I
think children can handle it I think
there's no ging over the fact that the
Empire is at the heart of a culture war
in Britain and I didn't want to pretend
otherwise with children because they'll
be taking the book back home and their
parents might be cross and I want them
to know that actually there are
different views you can make arguments
as long as they're based in hard fact
and again I think that that's a kind of
life changing concept I mean you
mentioned the culture wars do you think
this book will be seen as part of the
culture wars yeah I mean I occasionally
get accused of being a culture War right
but I would say look let's look at the
culture war and Empire on one side
there's people like me and historians
earnestly trying to base what we say on
facts and research and consensus on the
other side you've got the the government
who have pretty much taken you know got
involved in this culture war with with
full sincerity and passion and then
you've got powerful think taxs you've
got the right-wing media it's
pretty I feel pretty outnumbered so I
don't feel like I am the culture Warrior
I feel like they they are the culture
Warriors but this is the nature of
culture wars in that both sides accuse
each other of being culture Warriors but
I would say you know in general I'm
trying to reflect what historians think
the experts on the other side they're
trying to argue against the consensus of
what imp Imperial historians think and
it's part of a general battle against
the experts it happened with coid it
happened with brexit and it's happening
with
history do you feel that the culture
wars have entered the classroom I mean
you travel around schools quite a lot
you talk to teachers you talk to to
school children do you get a sense that
teachers are afraid to teach Empire
because they'll be you know picked up in
in by whichever Camp from from parents I
know so cuz I spoke to a the historical
associations Gathering of many history
teachers last week and they're full of
stories like people coming parents
coming saying why are you teaching my
children all this fake history about
Enoch pal who was right what do you say
to that as a teacher but also I think
there was a survey out a few months ago
Shing that people are going to libraries
saying why are you even stalking this
book it's a woke nonsense and in Florida
you've got down you know books being
banned and I feel like whatever happens
with the culture wars over there
eventually comes over here and I feel
like that is the next step and he made
me very nervous writing this book you
know because I know some parents are
going to be like this is nonsense cuz
they part of the culture wars and I do
acknowledge that you know our particular
brand of racism in Britain I think was
caused by British Empire and British
Empire was racist but there is an
argument now and the Fring is that
British Empire was never racist and
problem is you got to take that on you
know you can't gloss over it with kids
cuz the fact is the consensus among
every imperial history I've ever read
including Nile Ferguson Jan Morris
people who love the Empire is that
British Empire was was willfully racist
for at least a century and you've got to
say it whatever the people on the
fringes might
argue so I'm sure you know very well
that uh the Home Secretary a couple of
days ago SW bravman said white people
shouldn't feel guilty about Britain's
history and there is no future without
reverence of the past do you fear that
this book is going to be accused of not
being proud enough of Britain by daring
to mention the extent of slavery what
the East India Company did for example
of course you I get that all the time I
mean if you look on my Amazon reviews
loads of people clearly not read the
book giving it one star reviews saying
it's I'm Britain bashing yeah the book's
not out yet but that's great yeah
actually no the book got called vicious
brilliant in the Jewish Chronicle by a
right-wing journalist uh about three
months before I finished it so that's
what you're facing now I mean and you
know David ooga has a bodygard yeah it's
full on the cultureal wars it's actually
translating into actual it feels like
actual War sometimes and of course I'm
going to get accused of that but I
think the if you understand Empire it's
a really positive thing overall you know
for a start a lot of British people took
on the Empire throughout uh secondly yes
we we you know dominated the slave trade
for large periods but also we abolished
it and I say that in the book and then
yeah we've got we had racism which was
created by Empire but also we have a
Multicultural Society because of Empire
those things can coexist the problem in
the culture is that there's no room for
nuance but you talk about coexistence
and I wonder if with this book what
you're trying to show kids is that you
can be proud of your country but also
ask questions about your country and
that's and that's what it's equipping
them to do yeah if you love your say if
you really love your family I wrote a
family Memoir that was an expression of
love I sat there and sat through very
difficult stories things that pain me
but it's cuz I love my family that I
thought it was worthwhile similar with
your country if you truly love your
country you look at the history whats
and all to understand it the proper
truth rather than seeing it through a
prism of Pride or shame which is bizarre
because I mean why would you view
history through feelings your feelings
really do not matter and you would
consider yourself a patriate right yeah
I mean I am way too rightwing for some
people you know by saying things like
that well I'm a Centrist probably and
you know what this is all quite new I'm
think idea that uh you not you're not
properly British if you dare to observe
the massacres and the slavery is it's
it's a modern Trope and again created by
social media I
feel interesting isn't it I mean I've
seen the kind of stuff that you get on
social media uh and it's interesting
because other uh historians who are not
of color who say similar things don't
get any of that they're certainly not
walking around with bodyguards do you
ever think actually it's too much yeah I
do I actually more or less sto doing
events in Britain because actually the
trolling online is I'm so used to it it
doesn't really it doesn't feel real um
although it does get you when it's
Relentless for days out a time when you
get targeted but it's the it's the way
it translates into real life it's people
coming to my events and shouting at me
and you know when that happens it's
always makes for a good event in the
sense that other people stand up for me
it feels like the whole event matters
I I sell out of my books it's good I
mean know my publish it makes my
publisher happy but it comes at personal
cost to me I realized that I started
dreading the moment I was look waiting
to be attacked and I just stopped doing
those events and I just did
International ones but then I did
interview I did an event at jaipore
where you were there and you know there
was a journalist who writes for the
telegraph who wrote a very completely
skewed version of what happened happened
you just can't escape it really but I'm
now going to have to start doing these
events and I think I'm hoping the part
of the solution with stolen history is
to talk directly to schools and pupils I
find talking to students is much more
rewarding than talking to uh imperially
nostalgic adults who maybe had a very
one-sided
education I'm surprised to hear you say
that you don't um you kind of have tried
to avoid events here I mean you have not
had death threats have you you've not
you don't have a bodyguard no no I don't
but you
know yeah I mean it's quite I mean I'm
not the only one I do feel like uh black
historians get it worse and women women
of color get it absolutely the worst I
don't know what your experience has been
I mean writing about Empire as a woman
of
color um I think I for me it's not been
so much because remember I do it through
first- person testimony and so that's I
foreground their voices it's not it's
not mine so
much um so yeah but you don't want to
ask me about me Connor classic BBC
exactly uh got an aversion to making it
about yourself
um you said you really want to go around
schools uh and I know you like speaking
to school children um do you think the
Next Generation think differently about
Empire totally I mean I get the feeling
that they feel about museums and Empire
in general the way we felt about zoos I
remember going around Dudley Zoo as a
kid thinking why is this tiger trapped
in Dudley man it's not it's not right
you know and I feel like the new
generation feel definitely feel that
about museums you you hear hear them if
you go around the British museum first
of all you hear a lot of people from
Asia complaining about their precious
items being held by the British but also
I think you you hear from children think
saying quite challenging things which
you didn't hear in my generation and
yeah they really they really care about
it I get the sense also a lot of
children are going to school and saying
Miss sir teach me about colonialism you
know and that's new yeah that's a new
thing a lot of history teachers say that
and the curriculum doesn't give them
generally give them the space for it so
they're having to improvise I mean just
talking about the curriculum
um teaching the kind of history that you
talk about is not part of the curriculum
in England it is it is key stage three
there's a bit of Empire but not much
yeah key stage 3 has room to teach about
British Empire you have to choose to to
to teach it though don't you I think yes
there's a lot of discretion involved
there's a lot of discretion invol and
it's a huge period that that you it's
the biggest thing we ever did as a
country and it should be one of the
biggest things we teach and we don't um
do you think that it will one day be on
the curriculum and do you think it will
be in our lifetime absolutely it's
happening already and the Welsh
curriculum has changed it has teaching
slavery and clonalis there's a massive
movement in Scotland I suspect that will
happen within the next few years it's an
international thing that's changing and
France Germany the Netherlands
everything is changing when it comes to
colonialism but in Britain in England
there's a definite resistance to change
and so it's interesting so are you
saying that other European countries
former Colonial rulers do they do it
better or do they do it differently I'm
thinking in general like the Dutch royal
family have formly apologized for
slavery they've commissioned a committee
of historians to look into the history
the French have commissioned really
serious Research into what to do with
their colonial items Germany has paid
reparations you know they're just much
more on it and even America they there's
serious conversations about reparations
you know but in Britain our answer is no
we have legislation Banning the return
of items right and you saw it at the
coronation the gap between what the
commonwealth countries wanted to talk
about the reparations return of their
Loot and our total refusal to go into
well I mean King Charles did give a bit
of ground in KNE he's finally well
the the queen consult didn't wear the co
all yeah that was a kind of political
Dodge also he said he approves of the re
he the Royal archives being opened up to
research but we're talking about one PhD
researcher who might report by 2026
compared to what the Dutch royal family
are doing it's ridiculously small and
compared to how much of an issue it is
even within the Commonwealth the
Commonwealth I mean is we struggle to
say what it's for but one thing they
really do want to talk about is
reparations and it's the one thing we
don't want to talk
about um do you think it's helpful to
talk about decolonizing the
curriculum just that particular word do
you think that's quite a divisive word
yeah I think it's divisive I think it
puts people's backs up also I think
ultimately it's impossible so like if
you're going to
decolonize this room first of all we
wouldn't be here you know you got to
undo some profound things you know the
wealth that slavery produced is baked
into Britain it's like trying to take
you know the egg out of a baked cake you
can't compensate for slavery because you
You' be talking about trillions some
people do try to calculate the amount of
money and we're talking trillions and
trillions of pounds I thought that was
what was very interesting actually in
this book is that you when you're
talking about the wealth and you talk
about how Empire shaped towns and cities
and Countryside you you you really kind
try and draw that out in places around
the country so that children actually
look up and look at these buildings and
think about the wealth and how these
buildings came to be there um why was
that important to include that I think
with kids you've got to related it to
their lives and probably with adults too
and
uh that's one of the easiest ways I mean
so much so many everyday items like
nutmeg um HP Sauce wers Source all
arguably come from Empire which people
wouldn't think about I mean yeah I mean
I'm I'm always discour things I
discovered the other day that my English
course I did English at University
English was taught as an academic
subject in India before it was taught in
Britain and actually it was imported
into Britain a lot of the teaching
materials used in India was used here
that's amazing the idea that my English
courses also had a colonial element to
it it's but I'm always discovering I
discovered things whilst researching
stuff for this book you know which I had
thought about London Zoo I'd never
thought about how that had Colonial
Origins you know I didn't know a raffles
was involved in creating it and um
things keep coming up all the
time um one of the most important parts
of the book um which is actually a
really important part of understanding
Britain and Multicultural Britain is the
explanation of the 1948 nationality act
which was like kind of such a turning
point moment for me uh and probably you
too when I realized that actually there
was a piece of legislation that meant
that our moms and dads when they came
over were British citizens uh and that
that they were already British because
of because of Empire not all of them not
all of them but until the legislation
was undone of course but but initially
until until they kind of fundamentally
the people on the Wind Rush In The Wind
Rush exactly up until 1962 and then it
it began to be watered down um and so
that when people say go home actually
you know they were British where would
they go home to is that is that is that
why you kind of make a big point of it
in the book you're trying to show
children this kind of longer history
yeah and I think it's the most important
lesson because the wind everyone seems
to have forgotten about the wind Rush
Scandal but our government deported
British citizens to countries they
didn't even know you know because the
level of knowledge about Empire was so
poor amongst civil servants that's what
that's the real world consequence of not
knowing this history you know and that
was one of the things that the wind Rush
inquiry picked up on that we need to
teach people the basic fact that black
people in in the 1950s and 40s came as
Citizens and I still think that's really
poorly understood and I think it's
partly a consequence of the media
narrative endless idea that brown people
are Interlopers and don't really belong
and it's amazing that that narrative
persists when we have a British Asian
prime minister British Asian head head
of the S&P
it still persists doesn't it and it's
been really Bleak that the government
are watering down what they're going to
do about wind rush you know step by step
they did say they were going to take on
all the all the recommendations of the
report and now they're not and it's
shocking we should be more angry about
it I think people are angry for like a
month and then everyone's just forgotten
about it and but that's the direct
consequence of not knowing your history
and the same was in the Steven Lawrence
report as well wasn't it yeah it comes
up regularly it's like happens every 10
years everyone has a dark eye of the
Soul Britain feels really bad about its
own racism for about two weeks and then
we go back to the normal narrative which
is actually we are Beyond racism because
we beat the evil racist Nazis we
abolished slavery and now the narratives
we have a British Asian prime minister
therefore racism doesn't exist has never
existed it's just not
true what I think is really uh unusual
about your book is you give practical
advice to children about who face racism
um or how to challenge Silence about
learning about Empire but also really
importantly how to be an ally that you
you're giving lots of different types of
kids a
vocabulary why you why did you do that I
think uh I know well I I know from
personal experience that it can feel
very lonely you know having this
knowledge and a lot of people not having
it it can kind of make you feel isolated
and uh I just didn't want kids to read
all this information about ire Empire
and then not know what to do with it and
I think there are constructive ways to
talk about this stuff I mean it's too uh
competitive the way we talk about Empire
I think you can have a a debate within a
school about whether Sir Richard Drax
should pay reparations to the
descendants of the slaves that enriched
him and made him one of the richest MPS
in Parliament you can have a debate
about that with without it being toxic
you know and you can learn a lot of
things and you can you can be on both
sides I can see both sides of that
argument um I so I think kids are much
more flexible than we give them credit
for you say build a statue um that
you're not that into tearing down
statues what would be your
statue um I mainly not into T statues
because um I feel like there's Street
Furniture we only think about them in
recent years right um I'll put one on
for Dean Muhammad the first Indian who
ever wrote a book in English the first
Indian to open actually the first person
to open a Curry House in Britain and who
ended up being a kind massage therapist
for the king in Brighton um incredible
life and kind of forgotten I was an
Irish woman didn't he married Irish
woman yeah I been to be honest my whole
Adventure into Empire started with him
cuz I wanted I thought oh you know what
I'll write a novel about this amazing
weird guy and um I thought I better
research what it was like to come from
India and what it was like under the
East India Company and cuz he came over
with the East India
Company uh manager of sorts and I
started researching and that led to
Empire land so here we are oh I didn't
realize that well down to D Muhammad um
I've just been thinking a lot about
change um and because people talk about
apologies they talk about reparations
you mentioned some European countries
that are doing it considering it but
could change also be the next generation
and that they deal with this this
subject that in In Our Lifetime has
become so kind of as you say toxic they
just deal with it perhaps in a more
adult way yeah I think there's too much
focus on oh we got to change the
curriculum uh the curriculum doesn't
matter that much because acmis don't
have to teach it private school schools
don't have to teach it um and as we know
Wales and Scotland have different
curriculums and also I do feel like kids
are getting their knowledge from other
sources like uh podcast I mean the
Empire podcast is incredible you've been
you've both been on it haven't yeah and
uh rest is history I mean did an amazing
couple of episodes on Christopher
Columbus there's Instagram accounts like
the history Corridor run by a history
teacher black and brown history account
on his and you got I joined Tik Tok and
yesterday and uh I think your publisher
told you to do that I did and I've got
only a th000 views of one video and
probably 200 racist messages so the the
view to racist abuse ratio is incredible
but kids are getting their knowledge
from all sorts of different sources and
yeah the change is happening so you know
people on the far right can attempt to
take it on but I think it's having no
effect on the
young why is it at this particular
Moment In Time if you if we think about
the British Empire really drawing to an
end beginning with 1947 when they
withdrew from India why is it now 20 in
our 2023 that the Empire is so
incend why now I think about this a lot
it's like it's bizarre isn't it because
Empire ended a while ago why is it now
one of the biggest topics in the world
partly I think it's like I said earlier
the British destroyed the evidence and
historians are only just discovering
some of it the mmar case is a classic
example
um and even now you can't get Lord M
batton's papers right you can't read
them and he was such an important figure
for Indian independence but on top of
that I think the first postcolonial
generation I'm thinking here of people
like our parents who immigrated but also
the people running India and and Nigeria
and so on they were so focused on
building themselves like building India
and dealing frankly with all the
destruction caused by the British they
didn't have energy to go over the
history and I feel like new generations
have the time and
luxury uh to sit down and actually think
about it but maybe they feel more secure
to do that as well like their place here
absolutely and it's an amazing thing I
didn't think Britain would be as
confident about its multiculturalism as
it's become I don't think and and that's
actually a really important thing to say
that in our
lifetime so much has changed I mean when
we were kids to think that you and I
would be sitting here talking like this
we wouldn't have imagined it would we no
I I went back to my Cambridge College to
talk about Empire and it was amazing
that their English course has been
decolonized but it also really pissed me
off cuz it's like it's off air why did
we not have any of that you know it took
me so long and uh but yeah I mean it's
all different now isn't it so if things
have changed in our
lifetime maybe in our our lifetime we
will also see a time where actually we
are more comfortable about talking about
Empire and our past it's going to happen
I mean in a fundamental way truth
prevails you
cannot you can't suppress the truth man
it's going to come out you can fight it
you can try to uh call these people
people like us woke culture Warriors and
whatever you cannot argue with the facts
you cannot argue with a consensus
amongst Imperial historians that can
change but you need a lot of evidence
and so I think it's inevitable I just
wonder when you were that little kid in
in wolver Hampton um growing up in your
Punjabi
family what would having had a book like
this in your household have done for you
I think it would have given me a better
sense of place in in Britain it would
have made me help me understand the
racism that was all pervading in wolver
Hampton um but he would have explained
the seik psychology because the seik uh
identity as a martial race which is one
we've really gone for and embraced was
created by the British the seek
Community arguably grew to large numbers
in the 19th century because the British
adopted us as a a loyal race to fight
for them after we took their side
generally after 1857 right and so so
much about British seeks can be
explained by British Empire and I don't
think British seeks necessarily
understand that and I certainly didn't
know it no one's ever explained it to me
until I I found it said by historians in
quite obscure
books satam thank you the book uh stolen
history the truth about the British
Empire and how it shaped us is available
in your local Bookshop now I'm Kavita
Puri and you've been watching or
listening to intelligence squar thank
you